short tutorial i'm going to show you how
to run
principal component analysis in just a
few lines of code
in r so the first thing that we want to
do is call a library a library
contains a lot of different functions
that are going to be useful
and here we're going to use a library
called gg45
so this library will allow us to run
principal component analysis in just
one line and then we'll use an autoplot
function
to visualize our results so let's first
of all
load a gene expression table
now i have a gene expression table
already saved so i'm just going to grab
that link real quick
and in this link we'll have a gene
expression table
for 52 samples and they will only have
a small number of genes just for this
illustration
it's a tab delimited file so we have to
add here
sep equals t
and we'll also add header equals true
check name well we have and let's uh
take also row names
equals one so that will save our header
and the row data
separately from the actual data frame
now
we can run our principal component so we
can do
pr comp
expression table and
we can also plot the pca
so let's try that
okay so the code ran successfully you
can see down here success
running code we can look at this plot
this plot shows us
principal component 1 which contains
about 56 percent variability explains 56
variability between these elements
objects
and pc2 which is about 23
now the problem here is that this is a
visualization of principal component
analysis
for genes instead of the objects which
are the samples that we would like to
compare
so to do that all we need to do is
actually flip the table or
transpose the table so let's do that so
expression
table t and we'll do
transpose of the expression
table and here we just add a t
so let's try to run that
expression table okay so here
made a mistake
all right success running code let's
take a look at what we have
interesting now we have some groups that
emerge from this principle component
analysis
let's color these so that we can see
what they actually look like so first of
all
i can add here label equals true
and that will label the data for us
okay so here we have now labeling of
samples and we can see basal a group of
basal samples
normal-like clouded low and
luminal so these are some labels that we
will
refer to when we compare the different
groups
there's definitely a defined group of
luminal samples
a defined group of basal and normal
together and
also one of the luminal samples is here
and here we have the cloud and low
so it's already an interesting result
now pca itself
is sort of like taking a picture of a
group of people
from different angles so that we can
capture
as many faces as possible so in this
example
we can understand how
15 genes that define the objects
can help us understand differences
between
groups of samples in a complex data set
and we can start asking questions about
this data set how are these samples
different from each other and how are
these different
from within themselves so what is the
difference
between these samples and what are
similarities between these samples for
example
now if you want to learn more about pca
i highly recommend
going to our course on introduction to
data science
here you have a full course called
dimensionality reduction
pca and visualization and in this course
we go through this example in much
greater detail so you'll see here what
the table actually looks like
you'll be able to go through some
exercises and visualize these different
plots
in a more comprehensive way also adding
feature significance and even trying
clustering
so in this full course you will be able
to play around with your data
really try to run the different pieces
of code just like i did
and have a challenge at the end to try
and write a more complex visualization
that will be informative about the data
set that you're working with
so if you want to learn r and run
principal component analysis clustering
all kinds of machine learning techniques
i highly recommend this course
for you to try out so all you need to do
is sign up for free on code
opticslogic.com
and try learn how to develop these
skills
now after you're done you can also you
can always copy the code
and once the code is copied to your
clipboard take it over to rstudio to run
it independently
making sure that the files that you use
are also saved on your computer